[Music]
Gucci is a rare animal it must be
protected protected from home
I turned it into an Empire at least it's
my name
our name Milan Italy March 27 1995. a
man was walking on the steps leading to
his office when all of a sudden three
gunshots go off hitting the man in his
shoulder back in Temple as he fell to
the ground bleeding out to death but
when the police arrived they realized
that this was no ordinary man now this
man was none other than Maurizio Gucci
the head of the iconic Gucci Empire and
one of the most influential men in all
of Italy and now he lay dead on the
floor so the investigation was on who
killed Maurizio Gucci the problem was
there were too many potential suspects
that go around this was the man at the
top of Italian luxury after all and one
doesn't get to the top without making a
lot of enemies could a rival luxury
brand have called the hit could it have
come from inside the Gucci family for
two years the case remained cold until
an anonymous tip pinpointed a suspect
patrizia the ex-wife of the head of
Gucci This is the story of the House of
Gucci a story filled with family greed
betrayal backstabbings and ultimately
murder stay dangerous and let's get into
it
[Music]
today Gucci and their parent company
make over 10 billion euros collectively
10 billion not from techra Innovation
but purely from branding and Aesthetics
that is the power of branding and
Aesthetics and the easiest way to design
a brand is with canva.com a lot of you
already know canva.com as a great free
online design tool that lets any
beginner do literally anything from
social media access to editing photos
and videos but now they just launched
the almighty canva visual work suite and
it is a game changer if you got a
business or you're part of a creative or
marketing team the canva visual work
Suite basically takes all the tools and
subscriptions you typically have to
juggle and puts them all in one place so
you can plan create schedule and
publisher designs all Under One Roof you
can design and launch a fully
functioning website using their AI magic
right feature where you just type been a
prompt and canvas AI will generate all
the text on the website for you you can
edit Tick Tock videos and quickly sync
up the cuts to the beat of the song
thanks to their beatsync feature they've
even got a text to image feature where
you just type in the image you want in
canvas AI will generate for you so you
can use it in the social media posts you
create on canva for example and the best
part is that anyone on your team can
create this stuff super fast while
staying on brand even if they don't have
an eye for Aesthetics this is thanks to
Canvas brand Hub that allows you to
preset logos your Brand's color palette
fonts graphics and more so every design
you put out looks consistent a better
brand is going to make you more money so
pause the video and try the new canva
visual work suite for free for 45 days
right now with the link below that's a
month and a half of effortless design
for free with the link below thanks to
canva for sponsoring this video
it all started at a party it was 1970
and patrizia has set her eyes on
Maurizio Mauricio started out as a very
shy boy slightly awkward maybe this was
the result of his upbringing his mother
died when he was young leaving him to be
raised by his protective and controlling
father Rodolfo Patricia on the other
hand was a firecracker indulged by her
father and encouraged by her mother
patrizia loved the show off and was used
to getting what she wanted and now all
she wanted was Maurizio see Mauricio
wasn't just another boy he was a Gucci a
name recognized all over Italy
Maurizio's grandfather guccio Gucci
started his leather business in Florence
in 1921 after being inspired by his days
handling luggage at the esteem Savoy
Hotel in London and with the help of his
children most notably Mauricio's father
Rodolfo and his uncle Aldo the single
storefront blossomed into a global brand
so being aguchi meant more than just
name recognition it meant having the
world at your fingertips money power
status and Patricia wanted it all she
wanted the designer clothes the
expensive homes and most importantly the
money and the path of least resistance
to all of this was in her eyes Maurizio
it's easy to pass Patricia off as
materialistic but as she said herself
it's better to cry in Rolls-Royce than
to be happy in on a bicycle let's let's
for sure
see I was groomed for this throughout
her childhood her mother would dress her
up in fur coat and gaudy outfits all
with the purpose of training her to
steal a rich man's heart it was her
Destiny Patricia's mother was a single
mom and a waitress and before her mom
met her stepfather the man was already
married and he was fairly well off from
his transport business after his wife
died Patricia's mother was quick to fill
that void in his heart securing a better
life not only for herself but also her
daughter so marrying into a higher
income bracket was just part of the
family business for Patricia as for
Mauricio he was already destined to be
rich all the Gucci men got into the
family business but the women of the
Gucci family were not allowed no matter
how ballet they wanted to join they were
forbidden to as part of the patriarch's
dying wish but that was fine for
Patricia all she wanted was to be a
Gucci not labor for them so she set off
to enchant and seduce Mauricio but that
would be the easy part Patricia often
got compared to the legendary film star
Allah the tailor and her strong
personality would be very enticing to
the young man the hard part was getting
past the boy's father a man who was not
going to give up control over his son
that easily especially when he saw right
through her plans
[Music]
Mauricio's father Rodolfo hated Patricia
from the beginning before joining Gucci
Rodolfo worked as an actor fighting
early success in Italian Cinema so he
knew what real glamor looked like and it
did not look like Patricia all he saw
was a fake a gold digger nothing but a
low-class money-hungry woman trying to
weasel her way into the family fortune
but perhaps he was to blame for her
since naivete summer after summer while
dafo sent marito to New York to work
under his uncle Aldo it was important
for a Gucci man to get familiar with the
family business but maybe he worked
Mauricio too hard to where he never had
any time to socialize with women he
never got to learn the difference
between a woman who loved him and those
who only loved him for his money but
Patricia didn't give up so easily even
with Mauricio's father's resistance she
may have been small but her dreams were
big and she was not gonna let anyone get
in her way what she needed to do was to
get Maurizio away from the influence of
his father to do so she invited Mauricio
to her weekend house for a few days at
first his father refused he wanted his
son to have nothing to deal with that
woman but when Mauricio declined the
invitation Patricia ridicued him for
being treated like a child for not
standing up for himself she Pota his
insecurities and she pushed Mauricio to
stand up for himself which eventually
led to Rodolfo allowing Maurizio to
spend only the day with her but the day
quickly turned into night which quickly
turned into the next morning Furious
that his son disobeyed him Rodolfo did
the unthinkable he kicked Mauricio out
of the house and out of Gucci for good
with nowhere else to go Mauricio stayed
with Patricia and now that he was out of
work he ended up working at Patricia's
father's transport business it was a
strange sight to Behold a Gucci working
at such a dirty low-class transport
business Patricia had won she had won
the heart of aguchi but it came at a
price this Gucci had no power no
influence and no cash to his name
[Music]
foreign
Patricia needed to find a way to get
Maurizio back into the family business
but Rodolfo still hated her and he
wasn't on speaking terms with his own
son and on top of that Maurizio wasn't
exactly thrilled about getting back into
the family business so Patricia did
something clever instead of trying to
make amends with Mauricio's father she
went around him altogether and went to
Mauricio's Uncle the same uncle Mauricio
spent his Summers with Aldo Gucci Aldo
worked on the Gucci since he was a young
man while his other siblings went off to
try other Pursuits before returning to
the family business although learned
what he could he started off as a
delivery boy for Gucci and Aldo worked
his way all the way up to the top it
became clear that Aldo had a nap for
business when Italy faced Global
sanctions after the country invaded
Ethiopia it was all though who traveled
across Europe to get business his
thinking was if the world didn't come to
Gucci Gucci would come to the world it
was also although who spearheaded the
American expansion of the brand opening
its first store in America in 1953 to a
lot of success ultimately solidify
himself as the brains behind Gucci he
was the real decision maker but since
Gucci was strictly a family business the
question of who would succeed although
constantly floated over his head who
would replace him once his time had come
luckily for Patricia none of all those
children seem to be up to the task as
each of them were content staying in
Europe boom Patricia had her opening so
here's what she did she approached the
Aging Aldo and convinced them to help
Mauricio and his father make amends and
she convinced them to have Mauricio come
work for him in New York an award to
Mauricio agreed they moved to New York
he became a Gucci once more which meant
that Patricia had finally did it she was
finally a real Gucci it was a genius
move and Patricia's time in New York was
nothing short of decadent she filled the
years with chauffeur cars stays at the
Saint Regis Hotel thousands of dollars
worth of flowers a month and she even
managed to commence Rodolfo the man who
had hated her to buy her a couple
massive Penthouse Apartments in New York
Patricia's talented for getting what she
wanted she left behind all the glitz was
an extremely an intelligent woman in
Another Universe a very woke could have
been Patricia destined to run the Gucci
Empire instead of Mauricio but her
biggest prize came after rodolfo's death
in 1983. Maurizio and by extension
Patricia received a hefty inheritance
including a house in Saint maritz
apartments in Milan in New York 20
million dollars and most importantly 50
of the Gucci Empire but trouble was on
the horizon Mauritius climbed to the top
had gotten to his head he was the man in
charge now and he had a Grand Vision for
Gucci he wanted Gucci to evolve because
the world around them was evolving but
the problem was although Mauricio was
the largest shareholder his 50 was still
not a controlling stake it wasn't enough
for him to call his shots on his own and
standing in his way was the man that
gave him everything although and all
those three children who owned the other
50 and since Gucci was already making
them a ton of money they were not on
board with Mauricio's Grand Visions one
bit but luckily that naive Mauricio had
now become just as ruthless as his wife
Patricia and he was not going to let his
own family stand in his way
[Music]
if Mauricio wanted his way he knew that
he would need to do the unthinkable he
would need to oust Aldo and to do that
he would need to convince one of his
cousins to help luckily there's a lot of
resentment in the Gucci family it was
only a question of who had the most
resentment to betray their own father
and the answer ended up being Paulo
Gucci the black sheep of the Gucci
family Paulo's life was in shambles he
tried to make it on his own but failed
miserably and now he was broke and he
was being sued by his own family Paulo
tried to launch his own brand using the
Gucci name but got struck with a lawsuit
by his own father who was afraid Paulo's
ugly offshoot would confuse customers
about Gucci there could only be one
Gucci after all so one Mauricio
approached him with a chance to get back
at his own father Paulo took full
advantage of it in exchange for dropping
all lawsuits and purchasing his shares
at a later date Paul of Buddha tadi
Throne his father from the Gucci Empire
and to instate Maurizio in his place if
that weren't enough Palo tipped out the
IRS about all those questionable
finances which put his own father in
jail for a year as punishment towards
his son although slash Paulo shares to a
measly 3.3 but that tiny percentage was
still enough to give Mauricio the
controlling stake he needed Maurizio had
done it he had gone from a naive boy
with little interest in the family
business to now standing over the entire
Gucci Empire on top of the corpses of
his own family's blood Maurizio had
become everything Patricia wanted him to
be and from the first order of business
he brought in an investment firm called
invescorp to buy Paulo shares so for the
first time an outsider owned a portion
of the family business tainting the
bloodline of the Gucci Empire forever
and mauritio got right to work in an
attempt to return Gucci to an exclusive
status Mauricio terminated a few revenue
streams as a form of quality control he
also set aside on the Japanese Market
that hadn't quite warmed up to the
Italian brand yets unsurprisingly these
moves decreased profits and little
demoricio know that invest Corp was just
as ruthless as he was just as invest
Corp had no issue taking out Mauricio's
family investorp also had no loyalty to
him either so in an ironic Twist of
Fates investor removed Mauricio from
Gucci altogether and bought his shares
for 150 million dollars so in an instant
Gucci was no longer a family-run
business Maurizio's Fall From Grace had
just started and it was far from over
yet
foreign
[Music]
his family from the Gucci Empire one by
one showing No Remorse Patricia his wife
who started it all was also not safe
from her husband's Fury she wanted
Mauricio to be strong but as the saying
goes be careful what you wish for as
Maurizio gained more power within Gucci
he felt freedom for the first time in
his life and he started growing tired of
Patricia's domineering ways to him his
wife simply replaced his controlling
father and he had had enough so in 1985
Maurizio lied to Patricia what was
supposed to be a short business trip
ended up being the last days of their
marriage Mauricio didn't even have the
decency to tell Patricia that he was
leaving her he instead sent a mutual
friend to teller Patricia left alone
after the divorce and living off of a
hefty alimony watch as Mauricio fell in
love with another woman Paola Frankie
Paula was a threat to Patricia not
because she stole her man but because if
they were to marry Patricia's the money
would be reduced Patricia had created a
monster in Mauricio and it was her
responsibility to destroy him and on
March 27 1995 in the early hours of the
morning on the steps of his office
Maurizio was assassinated hours after
her ex-husband's death Patricia
reclaimed his apartment and kicked out
Paola who had been living there with her
son the case remained cold for two years
police blamed corporate rivalry or a
business deal gone wrong but eventually
an anonymous tip LED investigators to
Patricia and after a five-month trial
where she strictly only wore Gucci the
story unraveled Patricia had hired a
Hitman to murder her ex-husband and when
asked by reporters why she didn't kill
Mauricio herself Patricia says she had
bad eyesight and didn't want to miss in
1998 Patricio was found guilty and since
the 29 years in prison Patricia was
offered Parole in 2011 but refused that
because it required her to work stating
that she had never worked her entire
life and she wasn't about to start in
2016 after 26 years in prison which
finally released at the age of 67. see
phase by her time in prison she told the
press that she still considers herself a
Gucci in fact she considered herself the
most Gucci of them all
[Music]
Johnny Johnny
and you want to know what other fashion
brand has a really dark and fascinating
history Coco Chanel Coco Chanel had very
humble beginnings she was an orphan that
would later go on to create the Chanel
brand but during World War II Coco
Chanel had lost control of her perfume
brand to a pair of Jewish brothers so
do Coco Chanel used her Connections in
nasty occupied France to try to oust the
Jewish brothers from the company and we
cover it all in a new video on our new
channel called luxury matters that you
can watch right now by clicking the card
on the screen we created this channel
because getting the masses to spend
thousands of dollars on inanimate
objects that cost a few dollars to make
is a very fascinating thing so click the
card on the screen to watch now
foreign